hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trendsenses.com so i'm here to make a
very quick update guys because i need to
go to a football match to see panama
playing in uh 10 minutes but today was a
very important day on amc and jme so i
want to go with you through the press
action to see what can happen next let's
get into it
all right so we're gonna start on amc
guys i did a video yesterday to remind
you the big picture so i'm here just
gonna uh for those who haven't watched
yesterday video just go watch it i'm
explaining what i think is happening uh
which is a massive move up to the 135
area of course there is no guarantee
about that and we are here to monitor if
everything is happening like we think it
should happen so the first thing we can
check
is uh so i was expecting yesterday to
have a small correction a small
consolidation below the 32-33 area where
we got rejected
on
tuesday
yes exactly so yesterday
and i was expecting i said that i think
this would last between two days and
seven days all right and in terms of
level we can uh we have the first wave
that already happened which is uh going
from 13 to 33 guys so we can uh to
predict where the second wave could
bottom if we are developing in five
waves up we can use fib ratios 38.2 and
61.8 percent to know where the second
wave pullback might be going to and i
told you that yesterday that the 38.2
uh which is around 26 is the most likely
uh level to be hit it got hit today and
it was more than hit so let's quick
quickly have a look what happened around
this 26 level it got uh tested uh once
uh
it was tested basically five times and
then it broke you can see clearly it
broke with an increase in volume here
guys so this confirms that this level
was important there was a lot of bias
here i was personally about here i got
some shares uh and i'm happy to to get
it i will buy more on the downside
because like i said the 38.2 percent is
the most likely uh um ratio to be a hit
in the second wave pullback but we could
also go to the 61.8 which is around 21
and whenever you have those vibrations
that give you only areas guys then you
only use trend lines to know where are
the real supports 26 was a support i
just showed this to you guys we had an
increase in volume when we broke out
below that does it mean that tomorrow we
can go we can't go above that level of
course not in those very high volatility
periods we always have a little bit of
access above resistances and below
support so it's totally fine for me even
if as you can see the aftermarket is
right now at only 25 it's totally fine
for me i think that pretty pretty much
anything can happen we can go higher
tomorrow lower
bulls are still in control all right
bulls are in control as long as we stay
above 21 if we go below 21 guys it's not
looking good i hope it won't happen it
might happen i don't know i'm just
telling you that the usual development
in five waves that could go to
230 which is my target adjusted using
feed protections uh usually happens with
a secondary food bank that happens with
low volume and that goes to these ratios
so for now we have only hit the first
ratio and look at the volume guys
compared to the day before this is
wednesday volume
only 95 million shares traded compared
to uh tuesday volume where we had 212
and a monday volume where we had 226
million shares once again those volumes
compared to what we can do on amc guys
look at those small bars all right
they're big i know but they're small
compared to what happened in jan and in
may
especially in sorry in in may this is
may 21 so basically when we went to 17.
so what i mean is that for now we're
looking all good even if those if this
uh pullback we had today was let's be
honest a little bit stronger than it
should we had
it's better to move down with a smaller
move than we move up so that bulls keep
control uh here boots last little bit
control on the short term let's uh say
what it's uh what the truth which is
what is happening right now balls lost a
little bit of control but on the medium
term they're still in control as long as
we stay above 21. once again i don't
think we're gonna break out above 32
right now 323 around this 200-day moving
average so let's call it 33. i think it
would take a few more days i'm still
very bullish and as long as we are below
the 33 level i mean
uh the preferred scenario is of course
we go to 130 but we don't have the
confirmation to me yet we because i'm
using the logarithmic scale with the
upper bound try with the triangle upper
band that is around this level so we
don't have the confirmation yet that
this
move has started but this impulse that
is absolutely massive and very pure and
respecting everything that we like to
see in an impulse with high volume high
volatility is showing us that this
scenario is very close to happen uh
we're gonna have a look uh tomorrow guys
uh together at what is happening on the
option market but it's very hot the
volatility had got hit today uh i'm
gonna be personally buying calls uh very
soon probably on friday and uh early
next week if we're still in this levels
so i sum up the situation guys this is
to me looking like a second wave
pullback even if the volatility is a
little bit higher than what we expected
the volume is low which is good uh we
broke out below 26 but uh like i said
high volatility period always give us
some excesses so maybe we're gonna take
it back tomorrow maybe not if we uh keep
dropping it's totally fine i'm gonna buy
more shots at 21 we are still in control
uh and we are still developing i i think
in this five ways five five waves move
that can go guys 230 and maybe even
higher if the squeeze uh the real
squeeze happens now let's quickly go go
through gme press action uh jimmy was
stronger today jme only moved down by
seven percent so amc 12 gm7 i told you
in my video i did yesterday that those
two were trading at uh fair levels one
compared to the other one which means
that right now amc is is trending at the
discount yes right so jimmy had a
premium of five percent or amc had a
discount on five percent uh which means
that if you don't know what to buy it's
better to go to amc just looking at
probabilities um and we can see that as
well in the fact that gm is holding well
above the 200-day moving average where
whereas amc has not taken
taken it back yet jamie is also holding
strong above the 160 level uh even
it didn't even touch it today whereas
amc has broken out below 26. once again
this breakout can be taken back easily
yesterday so gme is uh holding strong
which is a very good sign because we
know that if jme moves to 250 amc will
be trading guys around 45 okay
this is math and this is what could
happen so seeing that gm is holding well
is a very good sign for amc and is
giving me more confidence in the
scenario that i'm giving you guys so the
scenario on gm is exactly the same
we keep consolidating uh so the 21 level
of amc is the 120 level of gme so as
long as gm is above 130 i'm bullish and
i think that we're looking great uh now
the second wave pullback has last for
now two days we don't want to see this
correction lasting for more than a week
it can then last a little bit longer but
then it would not look perfectly as it
should
so that's it for me i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button so you're gonna be the
first to know when i upload anything new
and stay close to shore see you guys